going I'm coming back good very lovely
pretty good I'm going to be friends is
that one now habit let such as far as I
can tell I loved loved loved the film I
literally came out smiling being from
yes idiot and it was so great and you're
been so amazing it singing seriously
what are the talents musically have I
don't know I suppose it's about
discovering I am an amazing table tennis
player oh I mean really like Olympic
level like sorry no you're not that good
good to know that yeah it's like I seek
relief and science I might quit my job
one day and just become a full-time
table tennis player I'd really like to
see that a champion you all the way I'd
be that going in the stands every toilet
would you ensure cities only snow I make
it could be real now we're gonna stop
ramblings we do this rain it's right
Olney I listen for quietly and did you
enjoy the singing animal to the needy
was it something you have natural doing
you nervous about it how do I get in the
end I think it was a little sadness to
begin with I mean it it's about calm
down I have ever done this for a film
for yeah and once you're in it I mean
it's like the music is so dreamy and I
was like can I say that kinda voice to
the character and getting to tell the
story through song and dance and kind of
you know it's just sort of expands the
storytelling realm really and I think
once you get your head around that then
it becomes exciting definitely and
talking at something I love dancing but
I know my favorite and I looked up how
bad their selves was like leading the
way she's got me I love that
and did you anyway the first on the
dance floor yeah wrap party god no I'm
not sure that your adversary and I do
love dance and actually at the end of
the day when we shot that I made them
play
Pharrell happy happy I got everyone to
dance and we did like a massive beauty
and a beast cast conga line oh wow it's
surreal yeah awesome so the iconic
yellow dress
it took over 12,000 hours to make with
his Wow I know I know I just think if
you learn in your production it
I am so any respect at dopes an amazing
dress
as another fashion and how'd it feel on
draft day oh my goodness you know it's
like if I run anything about fashion
it's that it's about the process because
you want something to look wonderful and
magical obviously but also the stress
had to be like a dream of a dress to
dance in like it kind of had to like you
know when you watch the animation and
the dress coming like 12 around after
her and it has like it's like a cloud
it's like so anyway we wanted to make it
true to time but also kind of like dance
beautifully and whatever else oh there
are so many different versions of this
dress and when he arrives on dance day
it just felt perfect like it was a lot
went into it but I think it a lot a lot
of different versions going through and
while while they were designing the
dress Emma came over for dinner and met
my daughter and he was five at the time
just so cute and we were talking about
it cuz it's you know we talked about
happening at work and and Willow ever
heard this and she she went next door
with a pencil paper and came back with
four or five little pencil skirt like
this and she was talking to Emma right
more very deep and you get true and and
then she came on dress day and she was
like it like a gentle children have
strong beliefs oh yeah ah
she needs a credit in here yeah and
should I give you credit in life and
knowing and saying how did you get into
beast mode did you picture anyone in
particular
or did you have any previously rituals
ooh
and I said getting in the suit got me in
quite a good headspace for being quite
sordid
also never see anyone eat as much I must
say it was like Brad Pitt movie it was
like every time I looked it down he was
holding something eating something about
to eat something yeah I was consuming a
lot of protein and calories just to
because I was burning so much yeah every
step was you know extremely Lazarus
carrying the way motherfu you see the
suit was about 40 or 50 pounds and slimy
it was it was a heavy heavy piece and
yeah just sort of physic getting myself
in a physical shape to puppeteer the
suit with it was quite something
how was it to work with an opposing and
maybe that's pretty cool that he was
lovely wasn't she I mean I think you
know obviously it was mostly her voice
that I haven't said but she was around
for the the scenes where she was
transformed back and she has a very good
motherly she takes writers on the sets
and night I felt her presence um the
original obviously is so brilliant
you're like who could possibly do it as
well anyway olya Emma Thompson obviously
she's awesome
and for this film is all about what lies
beneath the surface and rather than
relying on you know first impressions so
it's a timely message for the tender
generation that we live in
do you agree well there is something
sort of tender like about the prince's
first dance at the beginning of the ball
that kind of idea of him whirling
through sixty princesses and not really
connecting with any of them and so
that's a tiny little glimpse of a
backstory want we wanted to give early
on and actually it counterpoints really
nicely with the magical central dance
and where Belle reminds the Beast how
special it is to dance it off with one
special person
guys I'm going to buy again I might cry
I found hope you can eat your best for a
whole 90 minute